welcome to the man of recaps this is
cobra kai season five remember at the
end of season four cobra kai won the all
valley karate tournament and now they're
expanding taking over the whole valley
then terry silver framed his co-sensei
john crease to take full control of
cobra kai their starfighter tory nichols
feels bad about her window because she
found out she only won because silver
paid off the ref she confronts him about
it but he's like hey it was just an
insurance policy you won that fight
anyway so she decides to stay for now
now the deal was losers of the
tournament shut down their dojos and
daniel lavrusso sticking to it he closes
miyagido but he's not done fighting he
just wants the kid safely out of it
because he's bringing in some adult
backup his new friend chosen who was the
villain in karate kid 2. now remember
miguel diaz left the tournament last
season to go down and find his
biological father in mexico his karate
dad johnny lawrence is following him
down there to help and he's brought
along his son robbie keane who he's just
reconnected with long story short miguel
finds his dad who seems like a really
nice guy but johnny picked up some of
the cheesy touristy female body
inspector t-shirts so they walk in
dressed as the fbi and miguel's dad is a
drug lord so he doesn't appreciate that
and it ends up with some karate and now
miguel sees his father's not a great guy
so he calls his mom to apologize and
makes up with his karate dad johnny now
every season so far some new villain
from the karate kid movies show up and
chosen and daniel realize there's only
one left from karate kid 3 karate's bad
boy mike barnes they track him down and
it sounds like he's up to no good but
when daniel rushes in to confront him
it's like what my teenage karate rival
yeah he's out of the karate game he owns
a furniture store now and it's like look
larusso i'm so sorry about how i treated
you back then when daniel tells him
cobra guy's back and the karate war's
back on it's like yeah man i'll do what
i can to help but darth ponytail terry
silver is always one step ahead and he
immediately takes barnes off the table
by burning down his furniture store now
silver comes after larusso's personal
life when he tricks daniel into pushing
him getting his wife kicked off the
charity and it's like daniel i've had
enough of this karate nonsense she goes
to stay with her cousin who turns out is
none other than jessica andrews the girl
from karate kid 3 but she fills amanda
in on how terry silver is an absolute
psychopath and so after this amanda
larusso's on her husband's side all the
way back home daniel gets a mysterious
note about john crease and stingray yeah
remember silver beat him up then framed
crease for it so he could take over to
pay him off silver give stingray
johnny's old awesome cobra kai
challenger and sets him up in a fancy
new apartment so when daniel confronts
him he's not talking now it turns out it
was tori who sent daniel this note
because she's working for her karate
grandpa john crease turns out it was him
who convinced her to stick with cobra
kai undercover to get revenge on silver
crease has a funny plot in prison where
he's bullied by the jello man but then
beats him up with karate i'm the jello
man now now it's time to check in on the
karate rival love square miguel and
samantha russo got back together last
season but now she's like hey i need to
take some time for myself let's just be
friends robbie and tori also have
problems he's realized now that cobra
kai is evil but she's not ready to leave
yet so they go on a break too so the
older kids are sick of the karate war
but the younger generations keeping it
going anthony larusso was bullying new
kid kenny payne but then kenny payne
learned karate and now he's become the
bully his mentor robbie tries to tell
him kobrakai is not the way but kenny
doesn't want to hear it so with the
karate war back on original rivals
robbie and miguel are back at it johnny
lawrence doesn't want these two fighting
because he's just got some big news from
his girlfriend miguel's mom she's
pregnant he was a bad father the first
time around he's committed to doing
better this time and he needs his son
and his karate son to work things out
the only way they know how by doing
karate so yeah it's the mcgill robbie
rematch but things get bad when they go
upstairs because remember at the end of
season 2 when robbie kicked miguel off
the balcony but this time miguel stops
the fight and these two finally talk out
their issues and the beef is squashed
for good so cobra kai's been trying to
recruit new senseis but earlier chosen
went and beat them all up so now terry
silver brings in the big guns flies out
a bunch of karate masters from asia who
i think are actual ninja assassins so
now cobra kai's taken over the whole
valley and it's up to our crew to stand
up to him all our main characters under
one banner ready to take cobra kai down
for good so with all the main characters
fully good guys now who does cobra kai
have left well tori is still there and
she starts mentoring devin lee who we
met last season for guys they got the
random bully kid but the real star is
kenny who's come a long way real quick
and is terry silver's new favorite now
turns out terry silver's evil karate
plan isn't just to conquer the valley he
wants to take cobra kai global by
winning the world's karate championship
the sakai taikai but now miyagi does
entering too although there's some
confusion about what their dojo name is
johnny's still attached to his eagle
fang but they masterfully combine styles
miyagido's inner peace with eagle fang's
badassery so to decide which dojo gets
the spot it obviously comes down to a
mini tournament boys match pits kenny
against the current champ hawk but
kenny's come a long way and in fact
terry silver taught him the silver
bullet it's a cheap shot that almost
seriously injures hawk but it gets cobra
kai the win but now tori realizes terry
silvers paid off the ref again and she's
not going to stand for that she
disappears without explanation so going
against samantha larusso is our new girl
devin devin's a great fighter but sam's
got her out classed unfortunately the
ref is 100 bot but sam's not losing to
bad calls again so she goes into beast
mode and wins so definitively even the
corrupt draft has to admit it so with
cobra kai and miyagi fang each getting a
win the saikai taikai lets them both in
that night tori comes clean to samantha
about how the ref was also bribed at the
tournament and our girl rivals finally
talk it out and squash that beef too so
our king breaks into the cobra kai dojo
to get the security footage proof of the
cheating but someone tipped off cobra
kai yes they have a traitor yes it's
this minor character whose big arc is
that he's sick of being called penis
breath and so once again it's time for a
big karate brawl yeah yeah meanwhile the
adults are out celebrating too and after
four seasons of intense rivalry daniel
larusso and johnny lawrence finally
squash their beef and our best friends
chosen still here too by the way and
becomes their new best friend it's an
awesome boys night out until their limo
is hijacked but it's not terry silver
it's mike barnes who blames larusso for
ruining his life soon the guys convince
him it's terry silver's fault and he's
like well let's go over there right now
and beat his ass former karate villains
johnny and chosen think this is a great
idea so they leave larusso here and the
villains of karate kids one two and
three break into terry silver's house
but he's not alone apparently he's got
all his new senseis living with him and
who are these people i mean this guy's
got an eye patch mike barnes gets taken
out in one hit and things aren't going
good for johnny until he remembers his
unborn baby and goes super saiyan takes
these guys all out the meanwhile chosen
goes for the 1v1 with terry silver using
deadly weapons and outside in his
decorative fountain these two have a
samurai fight eventually chosen gets the
upper hand but terry silver goes for the
cheap shot oh um is chosen dead then
larusso gets a ride from none other than
stingray who feels bad and is ready to
come clean but just as daniel gets there
the videos finished uploading they cast
it to the tvs and now all of cobra kai
learns their sensei cheated so for some
reason it comes down to a final karate
fight between terry silver and daniel
larusso yeah yeah old dude karate time
but larusso's no longer messing around
in fact oh my god it's happening the
flying crane kick yeah
so all the cobra kai kids are ready to
be good guys now and the karate rival
love square all get back together chosen
survived by the way tis but a scratch
and stingray tells the truth it was
terry silver who assaulted him so terry
silver is going to jail cobra kai's
defeated and the day is saved but we're
not done yet because there's news about
john crease during a jello fight crease
got shanked but wait that's not blood
it's jello oh crease beats up all these
guards no mere prison can hold john
crease and that's where cobra kai season
5 comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]